[Music]
no matter how hard our volunteers try
they can hardly frown
you have beautiful youthful skin why
would you consider doing something like
this my family especially on dad's side
they've all got killer wrinkles yeah um
and then also i've got heaps of friends
at work that have had it done and all
their skin looks nice and smooth and
clear you know we live
my whole day on zoom now and i've just
you know you don't really look at anyone
else in the meeting you just look at
yourself
so this is a pandemic thing yeah have
you told your kids i have told them yes
they think i don't need it and they
think i'm going to look weird after it
well
children
each participant receives standard
anti-wrinkle doses in their frown lines
and crow's feet
that's amazing
super fast right
you feeling okay
whoops
a little bit of blood but that's nothing
little yeah
that was big
is it a hard discussion to have because
you know we tell our kids you're perfect
and beautiful the way you are you know
is it is it sending a mixed message well
i wasn't born with wrinkles
and you spend much time on on instagram
or tick tock a fair amount of time um
but i'm slowly pulling back you know
once you like one post that
instagram starts to
um show you more of the same thing and i
think
that it's exhausting what's exhausting
about it seeing a lot of people spend a
lot of money getting botox and fillers
to you know be a kardashian and
it's just a bit of a cycle that's not
very positive
on your brain like even if you're not
thinking about it all the time it's
subconscious
recent research suggests that paralyzing
our faces with anti-wrinkle treatments
could have a significant impact on how
we interact with others
on the surface our first time
anti-wrinklers are enjoying a new
glowing complexion
but what's happening behind their frozen
brows
now no matter how hard our volunteers
try they can hardly frown
[Music]
it is so good to see you all again i
don't know some of you might be in a bad
mood but i can't tell because you can't
frown you're next
i already get botox so there's nothing
nothing new here nothing to see here
but you have done this before you know
the drill okay your time starts now
our participants are again trying to
correctly name facial expressions in a
repeat of the three baseline tests
first as a group
then in pairs
to see if the benefits of a smoother
complexion may come at a cost
one of the key ways we interpret the
motions in others is by copying what we
see
the theory is that when we see
a facial expression we spontaneously
mimic that and it's thought that that
process of mimicking a facial expression
actually allows us to kind of
recreate
in our own body the emotion that someone
is feeling and then that enables us to
recognize the emotions with the tasks
complete
how do they feel they went the second
time around
i actually found it harder to sort of
differentiate what emotions are feeling
i struggle to
differentiate between the mouth and the
eyes um so it took me a little bit
longer i think the second time i felt it
took me
longer um to analyze the true emotions
of of the faces that i saw
and i don't know why
so it seems that anti-wrinkle treatments
around the eyes and forehead have had an
impact but what does the data show
okay so i'm dying to find out what the
results are how did our frozen friends
do our participants performed five
percent worse um following botox okay
test two they're about 200 milliseconds
slower to recognize
facial expressions
our participants were five percent less
accurate identifying emotions and 20
percent slower at labeling the
expressions
so test three where the faces popped up
really far like really quickly how did
they go there what we found is that
they're actually less accurate
recognizing those facial expressions and
the difficulty seems to be pronounced
for recognizing um negative facial
expressions like anger okay so now that
they've had botox
they're less likely to accurately
identify expressions and they are slower
in their responses to
expressions yeah that's what that's what
the data suggests
the results indicate that injectables
could have a significant impact on how
we interact with others
because when you can't read someone's
expression properly
it can also affect your ability to feel
the related emotion
we seem to at least temporarily lose our
ability to empathize
[Music]